heftige schneefälle sturm und eisregen
deutschland droht das größte winterchaos
seit jahren einen tag früher als geplant
erste impfdosen von astrazeneca sind
jetzt auch in deutschland vor dem corona
gipfel diskutieren die bundesländer über
lockerungen und erstmals seit den
olympischen spielen 2018 die nordischen
kombinierer feiern beim weltcup in
klingenthal einen dreifach erfolg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg abend willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne
für den sport hallo schön guten amt
bleiben sie wenn es gibt zu hause
zumindest wenn sie gerade im norden oder
in der mitte des landes sind denn dort
tobt sich in dieser nacht der winter aus
gewarnt wird vor extremem unwetter im
süden dagegen ein hauch von frühling
wetter extreme wie sie deutschland
selten erlebt und mit geologen warnen
das schlimmste kommt noch besonders
betroffen ein streifen in der mitte
deutschlands dort gibt es jetzt immer
stärkeren schneefall außerdem heftige
schneeverwehungen und im südlichen teil
von all dem eisregen mit spiegelglatten
straßen
einige zugverbindungen sind bereits
gesperrt und räumtrupps alarmiert volker
dutschek schneematsch und darunter eis
für autofahrer eine unheilvolle mischung
auch in thüringen vier menschen werden
in schleusingen in ihrem auto verletzt
als der fahrer den wagen nicht mehr zum
stehen bringen kann
für die nacht wird in thüringen mit sehr
vielen neuschnee gerechnet
ganz im norden nahe flensburg wirbelt
der wind den alten schnee an neue
stellen mannshohe verwirrung und in den
nächsten stunden kommt auch hier noch
mehr runter die bahn hat vorgesorgt und
das personal an den bahnhöfen
aufgerüstet für heute und morgen sind
die fernverkehrszüge von hamburg in
richtung norden und in richtung ostsee
gestrichen
wir haben jetzt schon hotelkapazitäten
uns gesichert für alle die die nicht
weiterkommen sollten außerdem haben wir
eine kulanzregelung alle tickets gekauft
wurden können auch noch nach diesem
wochenende genutzt werden sieben tage
gültig nach ende der störung eisesglätte
bei rathenow im brandenburgischen hier
ist ein mittler sda mit 24.000 litern in
den graben geschleudert der fahrer ist
bei jedem wetter unterwegs
ich muss halt raus die kühe geben jedem
tag milch kein warmes wasser und keine
heizung in berlin-lichtenberg fällig das
bezirksamt 100 wohnungslose aus einer
notunterkunft in ein sicheres quartier
viele bewohner sind überrascht als sie
mitten in der nacht eines der größten
obdachlosen camps der hauptstadt
verlassen müssen
wir haben unsere kollegen in zwei der
mutmaßlich am stärksten betroffenen
regionen geschickt wir beginnen in
niedersachsen an der a 7 in seesen am
harz dort steht fabian köhler fabian in
der nacht werden heftige schneefälle
erwartet um welche dimensionen geht es
da ja also dass ich glaube was die
situation hier momentan noch am besten
beschreiben würde ist die sogenannte
ruhe vor dem sturm ist hat er jetzt
gerade ganz leicht angefangen zu
schneien
ich bin hier bei der autobahnmeisterei
und hier sagte man mir sind sie auf
jeden fall gut vorbereitet sämtliche
mitarbeiter sind hier dieses wochenende
im dienst das was den kolleginnen und
kollegen hier wirklich probleme bereiten
könnte sind die schneemengen die
vorhergesagt sind im südlichen
niedersachsen bis zu 40 zentimeter
schnee können hier über nacht fallen und
darstellt dann auch die räumen die sie
mitunter vor große herausforderung mit
dazu gibt es ein ostwind und dieser
ostwind sorgt halt eben auch womöglich
für schneeverwehungen bis zu einem meter
schnee verwirrung sagt der deutsche
wetterdienst können vorkommen und diese
schneeverwehungen können dann eben auch
nicht nur auf der autobahn auftreten
sondern vor allen dingen auch auf den
nebenstrecken dort wo die räumfahrzeuge
vielleicht nicht so schnell hinkommen
können und deshalb raten die behörden
den leuten eigentlich auch möglichst zu
hause zu bleiben und am besten das auto
stehen zu lassen in dieser nacht wir
gehen 300 kilometer weiter richtung
westen zu gast den edinger ins bergische
land in die nähe von olpe kassen worauf
müssen sich die menschen bei euch
einstellen
ja auch hier ist die lage momentan noch
ruhig ich stehe jetzt hier auf dem
bauhof der gemeinde reichshof im
bergischen land und hinter mir die
streufahrzeuge werden wahrscheinlich
heute abend auch noch ausrücken müssen
hier bereitet man sich vor die thw die
feuerwehr die rettungsdienste alle sind
in alarmbereitschaft hier in der gegend
kennt man sich gut mit eis und schnee
aus und doch ist das heute hier eine
ausnahme situation
man erwartet hier weniger schnee sondern
vielmehr eisregen die kalte luft wird
sich vermutlich am boden absetzen und zu
eisglätte führen
deshalb hat man die menschen hier
aufgerufen sich nicht in ihre autos zu
setzen sondern zu hause zu bleiben
also überall auto stehenlassen
dankeschön carsten edinger und fabian
köhler alle aktuellen entwicklungen
finden sie bei uns in einem live blog
online in der zdf- heute- app 60.000
menschen in deutschland sind bislang an
oder mit coop 19 gestorben am 18 april
plant bundespräsident steinmeier eine
zentrale gedenkfeier für sie so weit
dass in der pandemie möglich ist sollen
angehörige und die gesamte staatsspitze
teilnehmen
aktuell meldet das robert koch institut
weiter sinkende zahlen 10 1485 neue
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind 1836 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 689 weitere menschen starben an
oder mit dem virus
wenn die zahlen weiter sinken und die
virus mutationen keinen strich durch die
rechnung machen dann werden lockerungen
wahrscheinlicher auch hier stellt sich
die frage nach der reihenfolge welche
schulen dürfen als erster wieder
aufmachen und wie es mit der kultur
pablos sie lacht la he
die deutsche oper in berlin eines der
größten opernhäuser deutschlands ist
während des shutdowns menschenleer
auch die kultur hofft auf lockerungen
wie die aussehen könnten dazu haben die
länder jetzt einen drei stufen plan
vorgelegt musik und kunstschulen zuerst
dann museen und galerien theater und
kinos zuletzt auch in der politik sind
lockerungen angesichts sinkender
infektionszahlen wieder thema der
cdu-chef hat dabei eine klare priorität
schule bildung kinderbetreuung muss
absolute priorität haben wir irgendein
geschäft oder etwas anderes öffnen muss
die bildung für unsere kinder wieder in
gang gesetzt werden auch csu-chef söder
spricht von einer lockerung perspektive
mahnt aber zur vorsicht
die zahlen sind dann haben die aktiven
läufer ist
am mittwoch wollen bund und länder über
das weitere vorgehen beraten
der ministerpräsident von niedersachsen
drängt auf konkrete maßnahmen für ganz
deutschland
ich erwarte dass wir in der bund länder
runde klartext reden und möglichst
zeitnah beschließen nach welchen regeln
bundeseinheitlich eine lockerungs phase
eingeleitet würde ein kriterium für eine
lockerung sind fortschritte bei der
impfung und da gibt es gute nachrichten
bereits gestern traf die eigentlich für
heute erwartete erste lieferung des
impfstoffs von astrazeneca in
deutschland ein
insgesamt werden heute knapp 350.000
dosen an die bundesländer ausgeliefert
eigentlich wollte die afd in sachsen an
diesem wochenende nur bestimmen wer die
aussichtsreichen listenplätze für die
bundestagswahl im september bekommt doch
dann wurde am dienstag bekannt dass der
verfassungsschutz die sachsen afd als
verdachtsfall einstuft wegen
rechtsextremistischer bestrebungen das
hat die stoßrichtung dieses
landesparteitags deutlich verändert aus
dresden cornelia schiemenz nur
halbherzig kontrollieren die ordner die
einhaltung der masken und abstands
pflicht
als einzige partei hält die afg im
schatten einem präsenz parteitag ab mit
über 700 delegierten die bundestagswahl
fest im blick
30 prozent in sachsen so das ziel das
ist denke ich ein ergebnis was wir
erreichen können auch aktuellen umfragen
und das wenn man natürlich auch
versuchen thema in allen reden die
heraufstufung des sächsischen
landesverbandes zum verdachtsfall
man sieht sich als opfer der
verfassungsschutz möchte uns zwingen uns
von so genannten radikalen zu trennen um
sein plazet zu erringen
doch liebe freunde wenn wir die afg an
den wünschen des verfassungsschutz
ausrichten ist das experiment afd
gescheitert
der verfassungsschutz beobachtet die
landesverbände in sachsen anhalt
thüringen brandenburg und nun auch in
sachsen
außerdem seit vergangenem jahr den
flügel sowie die jugendorganisation
junge alternative für deutschland
möglicherweise dauert es nicht mehr
lange und die gesamte afd wird zum
verdachtsfall
die zeichen stehen auf beobachtung auch
im und einfach weil die koordination
zwischen den verschiedenen ämtern des
verfassungsschutzes ja auch auf
kooperationen eben angelegt ist und
wenig sinn macht wenn die einen
beobachten und die anderen nicht
die entscheidung liegt nun beim
bundesinnenminister und sie könnte schon
in den nächsten wochen fallen
in fünf wochen wird in baden württemberg
und rheinland pfalz gewählt nach dem
aktuellen politbarometer haben der grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann in
stuttgart aber auch die
sozialdemokratinnen malu dreyer immer
ins gute chancen ihre ämter zu
verteidigen
heute schauen wir nach rheinland pfalz
dort bewegt die menschen neben corona
vor allem der bereich bildung und schule
robbie cherry an berichtet an der brüder
grimm grundschule in ingelheim machen
sie das was möglich ist notbetreuung
videotelefonie das zurzeit so viel über
bildung gesprochen wird begrüßt
schulleiter großmann was ihn stört fast
immer geht es um versäumten lernstoff
viel wichtiger die vermittlung sozialer
kompetenzen in der schule und die
wertschätzung dafür kompetenzen wie
teamfähigkeit interdisziplinäres denken
flexibilität kreativität das fehlt
einfach so und das wird in der
öffentlichen diskussion oftmals
reduziert auf die stoffvermittlung im
rheinland-pfälzischen landtagswahlkampf
steht das thema bildung hoch im kurs
digitalisierung mehr lehrer innen
flexible betreuung damit werben die
parteien unter anderem die wichtigste
aufgabe für bildungsforschers
chancengleichheit schaffen
die habe in der pandemie besonders
gelitten die dringlichsten felder werden
sicherlich individuell auf die einzelnen
leistungen stände der schülerinnen und
schüler einzugehen die ungleichheiten
abzubauen
die digitalisierung nachhaltig wort zu
bereiten und den ganztag strategischer
zu nutzen
darüber hinaus haben viele bürgerinnen
und bürger eigene erwartungen an die
bildungspolitik kreiertes kind einen
kitaplatz
ja das ist auch ganz ganz schwieriges
thema aktuell wie gesagt ich kenne viele
leute die die warten jetzt seit einem
jahr anderthalb jahren auf einen
kita-platz thema digitalisierung des
zieht sich ja nicht nur durch die schule
sondern auch durch die ganze wirtschaft
ja also wir hinken da einfach hinterher
die bildung eines der wichtigsten themen
im landtagswahlkampf und weit über den
wahltermin hinaus jetzt zu einem thema
das immer noch ein riesen tabu ist dass
frauen beschnitten werden um ihre
jungfräulichkeit sicherzustellen oder
wegen sogenannter spirituelle reinheit
heute am internationalen tag gegen
weibliche genitalverstümmelung sollen
zu wort kommen betroffen sind weltweit
200 millionen frauen die meisten in
afrika und in asien aber auch hier unter
uns in deutschland leben geschätzt etwa
70.000 frauen die eine verstümmelung
erlitten haben und tausende mädchen sind
auch hier gefährdet stephanie ghadir
abdel moneim stammt aus dem sudan
dort wurden ihre genitalien verstümmelt
und zugenäht gegen ihren willen nach der
geburt der tochter die hebamme hat mich
einfach beschnitten
sie hat mich nicht gefragt sie dachte
das ist etwas normales was sie tun muss
sie litt still bis sie vom desert flower
center in berlin hört wie helfen sie
beschnittenen operieren lindern
schmerzen hören zu versuche ihn mit ganz
einfachen worten zu erklären was die
beschneidung für konsequenzen hat und
was vielleicht auch verändert sein
könnte
in vielen ländern afrikas aber auch in
asien hat die verstümmelung tradition
beschnitten wird oft mit rasierklingen
oder glasscherben etwa 10 bis 20 prozent
von ihnen sterben dabei auch in
deutschland sind immer mehr frauen
betroffen
es ist vor allen dingen darauf
zurückzuführen auf einwanderung aus
ländern in denen weibliche
genitalverstümmelung praktiziert wird
und wir gehen davon aus dass im mädchen
die aus communitys kommen in den wald
genitalverstümmelung praktiziert wird
auch fernab vom herkunftsland gefährdet
sind
er hat auch davon gehört die mädchen
würden in den ferien zur beschneidung
zurückgeschickt
es ist keine kultur dass es kriminalität
wir müssen das entschieden bekämpfen vor
allem auch hier in deutschland
menschenrechte sind menschenrechte und
verletzungen sind verletzungen
nun will sie auch anderen frauen zeigen
dass allein sie über ihren körper
bestimmen dürfen
nach dem militärputsch in myanmar hat
die regierung das internet fast komplett
sperren lassen
damit will sie die proteste verhindern
die sich meist über soziale medien
organisieren
trotzdem gingen wieder hunderte menschen
auf die straße um gegen die
machtübernahme zu demonstrieren
das militär in myanmar hatte sich vor
knapp einer woche zurück an die
staatsführung geputscht und
regierungschefin august festgesetzt und
von myanmar jetzt sowohl die met
wintersport und zwei ganz starken frauen
zwei medaillen für deutsche pilotinnen
bei der bob wm in altenberg khimki aus
wiesbaden gewinnt im zweierbob nach vier
läufen silber vor laura nolte aus
winterberg ganz vorn wieder kelly
humphries aus den usa im schneetreiben
von altenberg waren kind kalki und
ann-christin strack zwar im dritten
durchgang die tagesbestzeit können
humphries am ende aber nicht mehr
abfangen
platz zwei mit 35 hundertstel rückstand
nach vier läufen
dementsprechend sind wir auch erst mal
vom zweiten platz aus gegangen
die junioren weltmeisterin laura gewinnt
mit anschieberin deborah lee wie bronze
auf dem undankbaren vierten platz landet
stefanie schneider olympiasiegerin maria
maria manca wird sechster die beste
linie auf der anspruchsvollen bahn
findet aber titelverteidigerinnen haben
und in der männer konkurrenz nimmt
rekord weltmeister francesco friedrich
kurs auf seinen zehnten wm titel nach
zwei von vier läufen liegt er im zweier
bob souverän an der spitze die
entscheidung live bei uns im zdf
zwanzigster spieltag in der fußball
bundesliga hier sind die ergebnisse
leverkusen gelingt nach der pokalblamage
bei rot-weiss essen etwas
wiedergutmachung 5 2 gegen vfb stuttgart
freiburg dortmund 21 erneuter rückschlag
für die borussia leipzig gewinnt
souverän mit 3 zu 0 auf schalke mainz
union berlin 1 zu 0 augsburg wolfsburg 0
2 gestern hertha bsc bayern münchen 0 zu
1 das abendspiel gladbach gegen erster
fc köln sehen sie dann ausführlich bei
uns im zdf sportstudio
in der tabelle bleibt es beim
spitzen-trio bayern münchen leipzig
wolfsburg leverkusen vorerst vierter
dortmund auf 6 muss um die champions
league plätze fürchten freiburg
verbessert sich auf 8
keine veränderungen vorerst auf den
plätzen 10 bis 18 wobei die aussichten
für den tabellenletzten schalke immer
düsterer werden
mehr zum fußball dann im aktuellen
sportstudio heute abend zu gast nach 80
tagen auf dem meer weltumsegler boris
herrmann und die deutschen kombinierer
sind in blendender verfassung und
belegen die plätze eins bis drei beim
heim weltcup in klingenthal in
abwesenheit des norwegischen dominators
jahren magnus rieber sieht vincenz
geiger vor fabian rießle und eric
frenzel
seit den olympischen spielen 2018 gab es
ein solches bild nicht mehr an
dreifacherfolg mit vinzenz kaida an der
spitze nach einem sprung auf 131 5 meter
geht geiger von rang 14 aus ins rennen
in der dritten von fünf runden tut sich
im langlauf eine starke spitzengruppe
zusammen mit dabei fünf deutsche
am letzten anstieg die attacke von
geiger die entscheidenden meter die er
hier gut macht bringt er bis ins ziel
dritter saisonsieg für den oberstdorfer
dahinter der sprints um die podestplätze
rießle vor frenzel und dem finnen
tiroler rezek wird fünfter die deutschen
kombinierer in topform knapp drei wochen
vor der wm nun sind wir gespannt wie es
morgen weitergeht baba dankeschön gerne
während wir uns hier auf gewaltige
schneemengen einstellen sie der winter
in andorra plötzlich ganz anders aus
dort sind die eigentlich schneebedeckten
pyrenäen förmlich eingesendet mit einer
gelben staubschicht aus der
afrikanischen wüste sahara auch in den
schweizer alpen trüb der saharastaub die
luft ein gelbstich am himmel wie auch in
bayern
es gilt wie berichtet die warnung vor
extremem unwetter in der mitte
deutschlands mehr dazu und die genaue
prognose hat gleich katja honnefer das
wetter wird auch thema sein im heute
journal um viertel vor elf mit christian
sievers was sie auf sich auf haben wir
einen schönen abend und bis morgen wenn
sie mögen